if you're looking for some excuses to
return to the division it looks like
massive entertainment may have given you
plenty the first large update is
scheduled to release on April twelfth
and it'll include the first incursion
mission the mission is called Falcon
lost and takes place in Manhattan sewer
system incursions are basically the
divisions take on raids and require
teamwork and high level equipment there
are no checkpoints and two difficulties
hard mode and challenge mode the
recommended gear level for hard mode is
31 the update will also introduce new
sets of armor most of which can be found
within the new incursion mission and by
equipping matching gear sets you'll be
able to unlock new talents players will
also get a special weekly reward by
completing the incursion you can only
receive the special award once a week
unless you play through it with
different characters trading will also
make its debut in this update instead of
trading through menus players can simply
drop an item they've recently acquired
and a party member can pick it up the
catch is that only the players who are
with you when you found it are eligible
you'll only have two hours to transfer
an item once you've picked it up other
additions include a spectator camera and
supply drops supply drops can be found
in the dark zone and unlike other dark
zone loot these don't need to be
extracted for more on tom clancy's the
division you're already in the right
place
you